Final Fantasy 15 director Hajime Tabata
revealed a whole lot more about the
upcoming JRPG in an interview with
French cyclist video chill Shockers
translated the interview and dug up a
number of interesting bits and pieces
including that the Final Fantasy 15 team
consists of about 300 people worldwide
Tabata also said the game has just
entered the localization phase of
development and they're currently
working to balance different
environments experience games and
weapons as well as optimizing the frame
rate he said this time around there will
be less cinematic cutscenes than in
previous Final Fantasy games but they
intend to put more cinematic elements
into the actual game on the topic of
flying cars Tabata explained that you
need to customize the regalia to make it
fly and then all you need to do is hit a
button to get it airborne just like in
the trailer featured at squares
uncovered event Tabata added that they
will be announcing DLC plans for Final
Fantasy 15 this summer and he's
interested in doing a PC version once
the console version is out he said he
hopes to create a version of 15 which is
even more technically elaborate and that
incorporates the features they couldn't
include due to current technical
limitations Tabata did emphasize that
this wouldn't be a simple port of the
console version and they would
essentially need to begin almost from
scratch let me know in the comments what
you think about the latest on Final
Fantasy 15 and for everything else that
matters in gaming head to GameSpot calm